uh you're here for uh Michael toi this
big toi it's really a great uh
excitement and honor uh to have him here
he is the class of
1933 a professor of anthropology at
Columbia University um and he's here as
also as part of the dissolve inequality
uh series um and dissolve some of you
may know is a project that we started up
here as a as a counter idea to the soul
uh conference which as you may know
brought many rich people here to uh
figure out how to solve The World's
problems and some of us said well you're
not going to solve anything until you
dissolve uh the structures of inequality
uh that are keeping things in place uh
and how can we fight the systems of
inequality in terms of gender racial
economic and other inequalities as well
uh disolve this really focused on bottom
up Solutions uh aiming for a more
democratic even anarchic approaches to
change uh and we like to mix together
scholarship activism and art uh we're
aiming for a disol 2.0 uh conference uh
probably about a year from now next
February is what we're planning uh to
build on the unconference we had uh in
Paul of last year and also we had a
music Summit a dissolve inequality music
Summit a few weeks ago uh so we're
looking for people to participate uh so
please get in touch with me uh if you
have any interest in
that uh I think the idea of dissolve uh
is quite relevant to a lot of Mick TK's
work uh some of his earliest work uh
which I'm sure many of you are familiar
with the devil and commodity fetishism
in South America for example really
points to the ways that people living on
the periphery of the world capitalist
economy have a critical Vantage Point uh
and particularly focused on the
transition from peasant labor to wage
labor and how the image of the devil
offered a way to talk about this
transition and and really highlight
things uh that have become naturalized
to us uh Dynamics and uh uh and
inequalities that we've come to perceive
as just the way uh the world Works um
and you know I was reading this material
again recently and thinking about some
of the ways we're in a similar
transition now perhaps maybe we're
always uh in a position of trans
transition uh but there's ways in which
there is new attention uh to the
shortcomings of capitalism uh to the
ways it's producing more inequality not
less inequality and that this idea that
the rising economy would lift all boats
it's just not true uh and now we have
the data and and some of the
understanding of what's bringing that
about uh and especially at a time when
disruption uh is sort of a key word for
economics for politics for society and
it raised to a level of value as if
disruption is a good thing uh as if
disruption is the only way of the world
and we just have to accept these
disruptions whether they're in the form
of a gig economy uh a sharing economy a
peer economy whatever econ economy it is
it's one that's continuing to Reni uh on
a social contract uh between the capital
holders and Labor uh and so I think a
lot of the kinds of naturalization that
we see in uh in mix work that unravel
those naturalizations are incredibly
relevant
today mix work also draws attention to
uh the ways that the rhythms of language
uh the words uh the Poetry of
ethnography and of writing uh is
intimately connected to its critical
force uh and I think this is very
important I think we spend a lot of time
I spend a lot of time trying to work on
ideas what's the end analytical
potential what are the topics what are
the theorists I want to employ and
perhaps don't spend enough time thinking
about writing and and the power of
language and the importance of finding
words uh to express things in ways that
that Do defamiliarize The Familiar make
the familiar strange and the strange
familiar uh and I really love that about
mk's work uh in this emphasis on
ethnography as writing a form of poetry
uh a way of using the fairy tale
potential the fictional potential of
writing uh to open up new understandings
of the world he's written many books uh
let me highlight a few of them I
mentioned the devil and commodity
fetishism Shamanism colonialism and the
wild man 1987 the nervous system a
collection of essays from 1992 my meis
and alterity 1993 the magic of the state
1997 deface bement public secrecy in the
labor of the negative
1999 my cocaine Museum uh spectacular
work that came out in 2004 Walter
Benjamin's grave 2006 what color is
sacred
2009 uh and I swear I saw this I love
the title I swear I saw this uh drawings
in fieldwork notebooks namely my own
2011 uh and I just to end this
introduction i' just like to say a few
words about uh his most recent book
Beauty and the Beast uh which came out
in
2012 uh he starts out the book with this
lovely lovely uh idea he says Beauty and
the Beast poses the question of Beauty
in relation to to violence I'm wondering
why so many stories in Colombia about
cosmetic surgery which the author calls
Cosmic surgery take Delight in the death
or disfigurement of the patient
for what is for what is involved is not
simply the coexistence of Glamour and
Terror in the world around us but there
synergism if therefore I'm I'm talking
in mixed words here if therefore I
choose to write about this in a fair
tale mode it is to heighten not diminish
reality as well as its aesthetic surge
for is there not a powerful aesthetic at
the heart of
Terror and he ends with a quotee he says
he uses this quote as well he says
beauty is always doomed writes William
Burrows and T asks is that why it
shimmers so please join me in welcoming
mck
[Applause]
t
it is early fall in Brooklyn a Saturday
to be
exact I'm sitting outside I feel the
enery that is a sunny Saturday morning
which is quite different to a Friday
morning or a Sunday afternoon heavens
above think of the desert of the soul
that is Sunday
afternoon by contrast the ser of energy
I feel Saturday morning early fall is an
energy differentiated according to the
rhythms of a work a day week and to
rhythms in religious calendars that go
back ways I see nobody but nevertheless
I sense the energy of the great
multitude saying yes Saturday is
different for some it is the time of
religious observance for others it is
Carnival time building on forces
generated Friday night although things
are CH changing in this
Regard in London young Michael Harding
tells me Thursday night is the new
Friday night and I've heard this from
waiters in New York City as well how
does this happen do I theologist study
this sort of thing and what sort of
thing is it Anyway does it belong to
Fashion or does it belong to energy or
both because young Michael alternates
between being super social and
misanthropic I think he is in a good
position to assess the meaning of social
eny locked in a caravan on Hamstead
Heath reading and writing plays then
going out on the town he is a sensitive
judge of the wave perfecting the
anthropological strategy of participant
observation one moment all
in next moment standing back
watching in any event this wave of enity
is not a meaning
nor is it an
aect it is all that and none of that and
something more as early fall the grasses
Reed the squirrels gather acorns and the
bonds tighten between my body your body
and the body of the
world baruk Spinosa steps lightly on the
grass chatting with Mrs delway about the
latest delus and vatari book and
wondering about the return of the Dead
flying in great packs overhead while she
keeps a sharp eye out for Sorcerers
strolling on the heaths pursuing their
lines of
flight she survived Peter survived she
Muses lived in each other she being part
she was positive of the Trees of home
she of the houses there ugly rambling
all to bits and pieces as as it was part
of the people she had never met being
laid out like a Mist between the people
she knew best who lifted her on branches
as she had seen the trees lift the Mist
but it spread ever so far her life
herself Emil durheim had a memorable
phrase for the energy emitted by the
collective as on Saturday mornings like
this one which he first applied to what
he called Elementary forms of religious
life as he learned about such from an
ethnography of the native tribes of
central
Australia he regarded the secret sacred
rituals therein as effervescent
instances of society worshiping itself
but what I have in mind here Saturday
morning is somewhat less formal and
somewhat inco what Michelle theice in
his college of Sociology days called The
Sacred in everyday life an issue here is
whether certain social forms events and
Communications can create a surplus of
energy and what happens to that
surface in
199 in 192 a decade before Duram famous
book on religion or and marel Mos wrote
on Magic as something his basis lay in
an ether or stream of energy con ated by
right booed up by an indefinable sense
of the
Sacred appropriating the melanesian and
Polynesian term Mana they were a pains
to separate this from the
intellectualist approach to Magic as
something based on ideas in the minds of
individuals instead they conceived of
magic and manner in an allog together
different
register that of the
social larger than the sum of its parts
and and irreducible irreducible to
mechanistic cause and effect principles
or the socratic logic of
ideas just as a ritual a performance a
painting or a song is irreducible to
such
principles as both origin and
consequence of the stream of which it is
part Mana was conceptualized by hton
Mouse as the Confluence of what they
called Energy and mure such as feel in a
theater maybe before the curtain Rises
or perhaps during a lecture in a
university missing saying would be a
better term than M
young I want to add to this an
observation of my own that
transgressions are likely to make Mana
spread setting other manners into
action today Mana is back on the table
inflecting the concept of
energy
with magic especially as regards art
which you can think
of art that is you can think of as a
cunning energy trap like a solar
panel but what then is energy surely it
is no less a floating signifier than
Mana which was thus labeled and disposed
of by CL thros in his introduction to
the collected works of marel
M surely energy is what used to be
called an umbrella word or Worse still a
portmanto word meaning it means any
everything and nothing at
all these then are fluffy words
manner energy that nevertheless
nevertheless mean business D useful a be
for registering a sense of the human
collectivity nowhere more obvious in a
word energizing than in the work of
Joseph
voice in whose work fluff is Holy WR the
fluff may be the fabric or felt or fat
or honey these being the materials voice
uses to make transmit and store energy
especially social energy like my
Saturday morning or Saturday night or
voice idea of social
sculpture energy flows through his work
as much as it is the subject of his work
from its Beginnings right through to the
lemon light Capri battery he
made while morally ill on the island of
Capri could we have a first
show this was a yellow light bulb
screwed into an electric socket itself
plugged into a lemon a bright yellow
healthy looking lemon about the same
size and color as the light
valve the light glows softly charged
with the energy of the
linen who would have sunken the light is
also charged with fear and warnings as
to the vulnerability of nature which
will require much in the way
of wit read out in rechanneling the
energy flowing from the Sun as
represented by these two yellow orbs the
softly glowing light bulb and the in
congruous leg congruous level and then
there was honey
pum
than and then there was honey
pump in the workplace made for
documented number 6 1977 with a
margerine lubricated machine circulating
two tons of Honey throughout the 100
days of the exhibit absorbing and
distributing the energy generated by by
the lectures discussions and seminars
that were happening during the
[Applause]
exhibition here I am again in Brooklyn
that warm Saturday morning I feel the
sun warm my skin I become aware of the
noise of the wind in the trees great
gusts there are a hurricane is gathering
in the Caribbean I hear a plane overhead
a steady hum with white Vapor Trails and
the bless of the sky
what is the difference between energy
and sensation I wonder if we formulate
energy as a cause of a sensation and
habitually focus on the sensation what
happens to the energy behind it is it
part of our being which like
a Joseph voice organic art battery of
felt and fat stores this energy as
memory of its impact an impact that very
much seems beyond meaning in the usual
sense of the word
what shift in register occurs if we are
to think of the body as an organic art
battery is that what I mean by the B
unconscious which registers the energy
field that the magician works on the
field of my body your body and the body
of the world what body is that I
returned to an old isographic work where
I read of the people of the South
learning songs of sorcery from stones
that walk like men the deadliest song
being that of the white fish causing
slow asfixiation as the song eats the
person's insides waxing and waning with
the movement of the tides the illness
worsens unto
death omnipotence of thought says
Freud poetry of the body of the bodily
unconscious says I as to the Sun so warm
on my skin right now in this our Epoch
of global meltdown it gives without
receiving says b introducing his General
Economy based on
Deon meaning a wild spending sometimes
glassed as wasting Depon is a tricky
word an Alice in Wonderland word for no
matter how many synonyms you come up
with and no matter how much we take
problems of translation from the French
into account Deon resists definition as
if on purpose as if on purpose it wastes
definitional ambition like the sum of
the white fish eating insides in accord
with the
tide is this before because Deon
confounds Common Sense ideas about
consumption for what Bai was getting at
was non commmon sensical yet common
existing as a Subterranean energy flow
in all societies and geared towards
autodestructive spending hence
wasting meaning some sort of sacrifice
as well as sacrifice of proper
understanding sacrifice is that which
takes you out of yourself and
consecrates that which it
destroys this is another way of thinking
how things go together comust together I
guess I should say a Saturday way of
thinking when the energies of society
change direction and
intensity on a rooftop on a brownstone
in Brooklyn you get a great view of the
sky of Manhattan it is Sublime up there
a little frightening and certainly
disorienting the world pitches like a
ship at sea but you pretend it's normal
you feel your feet solid on the roof but
the rest of you feels anything but
stable the roofer however is oblivious
his back is to
Manhattan but he is thinking a lot about
Manhattan about the sky out of the blue
he asks and what's going to happen to
the World Trade
Center what the Muslims he replies now
that they're about to let all their
syrians in New
York he is scowling the view now seems
Sublime in a different way a roof in
Brooklyn with a leak funnel the energy
of fear and hate that white fish sun
again you see a Mana wave oscillating
over Manhattan that was 5 weeks before
the ISIS attack in Paris November 2015
and long before the man wave gold
Trump and my open mouth astonishment at
the chaos all around the owner of the
local hardware store who comes from
India tells me it's the Jews referring
to the extraordinary energy alive around
us right now in the form of
gentrification tearing down the old and
building up the new he means the hium of
Williamsburg they Supply the capital and
Brokers from Israel do the rest he
assures me handsome young black guy nods
in agreement close to the subway on the
sh on the shadow door of the slave
theater one which is seen better days
there's a handwritten sign in bold black
letters gentrification equals
genocide this used to be the worst area
for violence and crime in the city of
New York you could barely breathe
because of the energy there negative
energy is what they call it I guess the
young Mars and Engles in The Communist
Manifesto portrayed mid 19th century
capitalism as a whirlwind of energy of
construction and destruction echoed
famously by Joseph a century later and
later still by Marshall bman in his book
all is solid melts into a which
concludes with a chapter on the tearing
down of sections of the Bron where he
grew
up for freeways the Bazi has a vested
interest in destruction I seem to recall
him citing marks and angles after the
manifesto Marx came up with a formula C-
C prime meaning Capital creating more of
itself capital is all Saturday you could
say with now again sudden descents into
Sunday afternoons when the energy of the
week sinks to an all time
law the self-generating energy of C- C
Prime was analyzed by Marx as the result
of the institutionalization of Labor
power as a commodity understood by car
Pani mid 20th century as life itself
meaning I take it
vitalism if Mana is in mil as M and
Hubbert wrote then it is easy enough to
apply this to the commodification of
Labor as labor power which was Marx's
term labor power is what results from
energy human and non-human set into the
Matrix of the market mechanism providing
suggestive tropes linking Mana to the
commodity the fetishism of Commodities
Max's own
phrase is an outstanding one
of these tropes Max V's Spirit of
capitalism is another and then there is
George lucage his idea concerning what
he called the Phantom quality Phantom
quality of objectivity under capitalism
an essay written at the same time the D
morphed into
surrealism is Mana the Phantom in
objectivity in the capitalist universe
is this what defines Mana in the modern
world not resistance to commodification
but it's aloofness it slips between all
categories the floating signifier after
all changing shape at a
wom if the Sun and
capital provide examples of
self-generating energy destructive and
constructive as negative negative sacred
Force sorry if the Sun and capital
provide examples of of self-generating
energy destructive and constructive then
one of Jean J's accounts of
self-generating energy as negative
sacred Force emitted by objection theft
and sexuality in the thief's journal Jan
describes his stealing from a municipal
porn shop with his parent with his
partner G locked in a store room
awaiting Nightfall G no longer seemed
the ordinary guy you happen upon
somewhere or
other now he was he was a kind of
destroying
angel from within this little from
within this little fairy where where a h
was
confined they sprang forth a determined
and terrifying fellow ready for anything
primarily
murder he looks at gu g g looks at him
their muscles Harden into suits of armor
energy crackles between them they are
little generators these two thieves who
could be
murderers they are mobile hydroelectric
dams or at least solar panels and not
only are they prepared to kill anyone
who finds them they're prepared to kill
each other as well think on
it later we find Jan on the docks in
anwell it is night time his wel to cin
has dropped his trousers to his ankles
and has his back to Jan who spreads his
bcks but at the moment of penetration
tricks his client by tying his hands
tight and proceeds to not only Rob him
of his handsome watch and wallet but
Delights in having someone at his mercy
and a lavish scene of what Jana aspires
to most namely betrayal the Cent
whimpers Jan flashes his knife in the
man's face and in his self-consciously
oror authorial manner explains to the
reader that he wants to tell us with the
greatest Precision what this moment
means to him quote the cruelty in into
which I was forcing myself gave amazing
power not only to my body but to my mind
this is a fine example of
self-generating energy this amazing
power that is not only body but mind and
Janine goes on to tell us he committed
similar crimes in which I felt myself
growing vibrant mean Icy stiff gleaming
cutting like a sword
blade energy craves
form but more than that Love's jumping
form into transforms we call
Metamorphoses quote love swoops down on
me like a falcon from which fright I
employ the idea of a turtle dove he says
he feels his neck swell with a gentle
cuming quote a curious creature would
appear as if each of my emotions became
the animal it evokes anger rumbles
within my Cobra neck
the very same CRA slows his prig of the
turtle dove he retains only the
horseness and so it goes on and on in
sheer disregard of entropy in sheer
disregard of entropy and Newton
self-generating energy making more of
the
same William bars has a memorable scene
where in a boat sailing across a Placid
Lake is propelled by a man standing in
the STM jerking off the boat being
driven forward by ejaculation
but Tai has something similar with the
pineal eye which began as the anus
journeying to the crown of the head
where it explodes with fearful energy
ejaculating to the
sun are we bound to a phallic rendering
of energy and
art is energy
male surely not at least not your
standard Petra
normative the man jerking off in the
stern of the saling Bo on the smooth
Lake and the man robbing the porn shop a
preeminently negatively sacred gay man
in gay texts loving the wrong thing
finding glory in the wrong
thing you or doubled
over in tongue and cheap
humor bars as for women are they not the
epitome of negative sacred power
associated with witchcraft the horrors
of menstruation the left hand duplicity
and of course the
Moon it was after all Hebrew Eve who
reached the forbidden fruit it was grp
Pandora who couldn't remain slipping who
couldn't resist slipping the latch and
this is why women are beardless a great
philosopher assures us shopen they don't
need a mask meaning a beard because they
come into the world mask meaning
inherently devious and double-faced
this must be why Hubert and mouse claim
that along with the spirits of the Dead
women
worldwide or rather the idea of women is
the greatest source of magical energy
thanks to the marginal social status
tied to the mysteries of
sexuality childbirth and
menstruation there is only one other
source of magic that to my mind compare
competes with this and that is the magic
of
words
and that brings me to Texas and masking
or rather to mooning Texas as it was
this left-handed gossip generating
witchery that got me thinking about
society as enriching itself with a
special rising and a falling bound not
only to energy as with solar panels but
energy is bound to the mask and to that
mode of Storytelling we call gossip it's
allbound to the exuberance of
transgression and transmission of the
key element in public secrecy the
element of knowing what not to
know great as live n's gay science moon
in Texas is imprinted with the spirit of
the witch B who lifted her skirts to
expose herself and made de grieving the
rape of her daughter
laugh de then drinks the
Kon Greek which s say contains a
hallucina the skirt is to
Lower the Veil resumes its place and ni
advises sophomoric Seekers of wisdom to
leave it there public secret rest in
peace until the next
time
to give examples is in itself a mode
that
energizes an instance of self-generating
energy defying mutant and
entropy which again brings me to mooning
Texas an outcome of sorcery Shamanism
and teaching
anthropology let me
explain it began with a swerve away from
canonical texts in my teaching
anthropology courses in the early 1980s
to consider William
fogner
as I la d as a way of rethinking
teaching about death and specifically
the anthropology of death itself an
absurd
phrase the crazy Quil form and
incandescent reach of fous language got
to me combined as it was with
crisscrossing interior monologues of
family members carrying the mother's
corpse on a mule drawn cart through
Mississippi to its final resting place
now that is
anology this led me to a stin as
professor of performance studies and a
decade long love affair with what is
known as the Avant guard or european
avangard meaning for me daa and
surrealism mixed with Marxist Aesthetics
and mysticism as with BR and Benjamin I
craved forms of expression better suited
to my life-changing experience in rural
Colombia it was that which made me
realize how that social sciences have
pretty much one mode sarandi and that is
making sense of the social World by
giving it a structure if there is one
magic bestowing word the Abracadabra of
social science it has to be this word
structure even where it is not in your
face apparent it is there like hot lava
petrifying all in its path if ever there
was a free floating signifier it is that
word it is astonishing this petrifaction
the way it kills movement and life and
Mana in the name of Enlightenment more
than
that even it is a conquest designed to
show the prowess of the explainer of the
corpse of the
explained if not structure then Resort
is made to narrative as with as with
historians there was a story to be told
yet one which
denies one which denies the art of the
story
so as to come across objective and
scientific and not heaven forbid be
organically embedded as much in that
history as in the telling of
it my own experience had been different
I could not but understand reality as
splinted open into what I called
multiple realities jostling one another
with different interpretations and
perspectives in this I sought sucker in
William borrows
mu or magical Universe while at other
safer world of structure started to
dim the MU corresponds to a mode of talk
and thought that cannot be separated
from that which it
concerns with which it is in
snared and which it Embraces and Jou
till death does us
power this in turn is the result of
understanding reality as uneven and
surprising reality is always always
throws you a curve ball and you have to
be grateful for that dark as the vision
may
be this I felt with special force on
account of the stories of the corpses
dumped almost weekly alongside the roads
and bridges leading into the Agri
business town where I lived in the
interior of
Colombia the same spiraling
uncertainties liftoffs and chasms were
there at the Army checkpoints on the
Southern frontier and were whimsically
with the Contemporary versions of the
origins of the saints that peasants and
land and slavers told me
about another reality and another way of
thinking about reality beckoned for a
while I call this swiss cheese reality
characterized by irregular holes leading
to other holes depending on how you
slice
it the problem was how to put this in
language or more precisely
find a voice and a form that resonated
with it and learned from
it there was a solution or at least a
response to this problem and that was
the Shaman's night long singing in the
putaya river drainage of Columbia where
for more than 30 years I visited my
friend the Healer
Santiago what I drifted into was the
worldless
H H breaking sound into rivulets of
corporal oral implosion while sing
bodies became
lost in another worldly space of
laughter and
fear like attempts at defining Deon it
is impossible to adequately describe
this tumult as soon as it seems within
the grasp of words and what Hegel called
the understanding it evaporates
poof this is energy in Spades Restless
energy deons on loose
it was as if that singing that wordless
humming captured the energy of the
violence of sorcery and of aanda gorilla
campaign in the southern provinces not
to mention centuries of racism The
Scouting of the Moon through luminous
clouds The Stomping of the cattle in the
Corral and the whimpering of Sleeping
Dogs which raises the issue of how you
describe music as the Rivero and Rosario
shaking with brain disease dying down
the road and sees a spirit on her
shoulder who looks like
me while a white storekeeper thinks his
store is Bewitched and wants the song
sung there but the Indian tells you that
in all likelihood it is the bad Vibe the
store owner is creating flirting with
the girls in minis skirts attending bar
pissing off his
wife this is the same problem of finding
words for energy but then maybe the
whole point is that there are no words
but what I call
tempting the gap between words and
things
widening such that then right then those
tremendous gunshot sounds erupt from
even further down the throat where the
belly meets the belly of the world
correct all of this took me into
considering ways whereby the experiments
in language image and performance of the
European avard could mesh with such
material and in liven not many
anthropological writing but our post
lives my initial foray were through
Benjamin and d as in the final sections
of his essay on art at the age of
mechanical reproduction which led me to
the primitivism in Zurich dat and into
Huga ball with his Infamous medicine
man's act or magical Bishop performance
with Emy Hennings at at the piano in the
Cabaret voler in
1916 for me ug Ball's magical Bishop was
a drama back and forth of order and
disorder culminating in what looked like
the Triumph of the church and Order over
the futurist breakup of language in
sound
poetry of which he was an exponer this
Legend act culminated in Bell Ball's
collapse as he fell in a dead faint off
the stage into the audience shortly
thereafter he left Zurich with Emmy
Hennings wrote a book on angels and died
a few years later in Northern Italy at
least that was the story I lived by he
was a bit of a Balter says ER answer
Rach in his essay on B but then they
certainly were tough
times yet the Triumph of the church and
order is a bit of an illusion actually B
was able to finish his sound poem
breaking language up into strange tonged
nonsense syllables much like the shamans
I lived with in Colombia because at a
moment of Despair and mental collapse in
the performance according to Emmy
Hennings he heard in his mind the church
BS of his native town in Germany and
with this version of order was able to
complete the
disorder For Me Not only was this Gris
to my Mill grafting anthropology to
European Avon primitivism and to the
magic therein but equally to the point
was the argument against ordering as
intellection and explanation that I
later developed in my concept of the
nervous system that loomed to me first
as graffiti at a fairy stop in Sydney
Harbor when I was writing on the
violence of the rubber boom in the
Amazon at the turn of the
century hence my interest in reenacting
the magical mission I build a costume
like Hugo balls with a blue cardboard
tube chint floor pink Angels Wings a
folded
cardboard and a medicine man's chicle
hat the small group of anthropology
students were bewildered I think but I
bu I built the Zurich of 1916 with Lin
living around the corner from the
Cabaret b and a sound of trench warfare
audible at night marinetti not far
behind in the early 1980s I was invited
to give a talk to the University of
Texas at Austin and I decided to include
a portion of the magical Bishop act so
as to illustrate my
ideas because I I was unable to fit my
costume on the plane I settled for a
brown paper bag over my head with slips
for the eyes and the
mouth this bag sequence took up all of
three minutes in a talk of approximately
40 minutes the audience may have been
slightly
beused I don't
remember in fact I think I might have
been disappointed by like a reaction
arriving at Berkeley next day I was
greeted with eye popping questions what
were you doing with a bag on your head
why did you do a talk with a bag on your
head I was startled the news I mean news
traveled so fast even in that
pre-digital age and even more by the
discrepancy between what I thought was a
m flourish and what my question is
thought was a big
deal around the same time I was asked by
the chair of an academic Department to
apply for a job the process dragged on
for almost a year at the end of which
the person who invited me to apply
called to say that he just come from the
meeting the meeting and PR barely talk
he was so depressed and angry you have
many enemies was his opening
remark the committee decided against
me he added I gave talks with a bag over
my
head he refused to tell me who was on
the committee and who led the charge
metaphor excuse whatever but decidedly
bad
energy now these words deliberations
committed and reported refer to
behaviors no less bagged
head the mind without much by way of
data they see to they exud much by way
of secrecy and more to the point of
public secrecy as notably existent in
this quote the story of the bag head
winding its way through the back
channels of what makes social life
Lively is this not also an instance of
sorcery too even can sacrifice an
example of which Rene Gerard called the
scapegoat in his classic book on
violence and the
sacred which brings me to moon in Texas
25 years went by 25 Summers and long
Winters Ronald rean came and went into
dementia as did America while
neoliberalism gripped the globe and
George Bush invaded Iraq setting the
world on its course to Mayhem in search
of fuel to maintain the exuberance of C-
C Prime 25 years went by and I was
invited back to the University of
Texas to give a
talk
this time I brought no
bag as I waited for the audience to
settle a smiling woman Professor
welcomed me back saying how well she
recall my previous
talk when I Moon the
audience it was it was all part of her P
at first I didn't hear and then couldn't
believe what I was
hearing that could not be
unperturbed she responded oh ask dick he
he was sitting next to me dick is a
well-known professor in fotball studies
in the midwest I never emailed him
probably because I thought The Story So
Scandalous that the thought of raising
it with a stranger made me
hesitate reminding me of a story
attributed to Lyndon Baines Johnson
early in his political career in West
Texas concerning a campaign for Sheriff
when someone suggested
spreading the rumor that the opposition
candidate
pigs nobody will believe that was the
response yeah I watch him try to deny
it I guess is what I'm doing
here I emailed the woman Professor a few
times when I got home but I got no reply
which I thought was
strange to invoke energy at this point
is to stay out of the man different to
meaning and emotion while encompassing
both we feel a lack and the distinct s
like when the cloud hits and splits the
pinata we then try to pin words to that
whack and that thud as if this can do
more than really point to the
ripples to say the b head went
viral viral gets across the notion of
self-generating energy like contagion
during a
play Fraser of the golden bow has a
major category of sympathetic magic
named contagious just as Freud draws
attention to Contagion created by
transgression in his book on
Taho but what then is
Contagion ad do H think of anesis as
involving a very material contagion
which borrowing from the and V we could
call lines of flight consisting of
propulsions encompassing aggregations of
people and of imagery in states of
becoming the mes here is out of the
image in the rumor first the baged head
later the bare
bottom going viral suggests a great wave
which we can think of as the energy
generated by the fall of a waterfall the
same energy rabet Evol in his gargant
displays of private body parts and
functions mixing rolicking humor
alongside unspeakable violence as back
never tires of pointing out the dive
into the Never regions NE regions of the
body the genitalia and the anus and the
dive into the nether regions of the soul
is not to solidify or strengthen
society's Norms but to do quite the
opposite to break with hierarchy and
with order and generate
life that's back in on R going viral the
baghe head crackled with
Mana but the mooning what of
that
here we find ourselves at first on
accustomed terrain that of structural
oppositions and
Transformations but now this oppositions
seem constituted in such a way that they
undermine themselves in waves of
transgressive energy recalling nich's
breath of empty space after the death of
God as the moon female is to the sun
male so mooning has Cosmic resonance dis
displacing the sun along the line lines
Robert Herz depicted in his turn of the
century essay on the global predominance
of the right hand in which he depicts
the cosmic affiliation of the right side
of the body aligned with the sun good
magic law and patriarchy while the left
side is the then further the woman bad
magic and
illegality what happens to this scheme
when applied not to right and left but
to the top and bottom of the body and is
in transgress
as with
mooning first thing to note is how
mooning registers the febal circuit of
oppositions between face and genitalia
which insists that the face be uncovered
while the genitals and anus be covered
however with the bagged head transformed
by
Ruma into
Moone this is elegantly reversed by a
procedure aking to what I have described
in an essay on shamanic magic as a
skilled
revelation of skilled
concealment Freud writes of the
animistic world of so-called primitive
people passing into the unconscious
layers of the cyy of the so-called
civilized is the magical Shamanism of
the skill revelation of skill
concealment at work in the memories of
the audience an example of this
potentiated by the shamanic subject
matter of my
lecture Freud perceived an ID likee
primitive quality animating
crowds to the extent that this applies
even to the intellectually focused
audiences at a university
lecture would not this ID quality be
conducive to just such shamanic magic of
skill revelation of skill
concealment in this regard Howen to
donos drawing attention to the Primitive
character of modern audiences at a
classical music
concert even if they are subject to
super ego controls or in NES formulation
to the instinctual control of the
instincts as with Homer's
Sirens adus the audience is understood
as maintaining a Vigilant distance from
the music but unless bound to the MK
will succumb to the music's
magic could something parallel to this
mix of repression and play being at work
in my talk including my hugar Ball
performance ask yourself what it means
ask yourself what it means to insert
performance into a
lecture is it not incitement to
Switching gears and letting the sirens
loose above all you might wonder at the
comedy in all of this which when all is
said and done lies just below the
surface of academic
lecturing mooning is not that
far from the man what I call the Mana
shock M shock that men feel when
confronting women bearing the Vala to
frighten off and shame of men this has
been noted in West and East Africa for
example and was disced to me by women
protesting changes threatened by a newly
elected right-wing
government threatening changes to the
Australian Broadcasting Corporation in
the 1970s the women sat on the steps and
flashed the police as they tried to
remove the protesters and initially at
least the police recoil I've heard that
adoro himself was flashed while
lecturing in Frankfurt at the time he
took a hard line against what uh he
perceived as a libertarianism
libertinism of of the of the 60s Daniela
gondolo has analyzed at length the
repulsion of the Lima police in Peru
when a middle-aged street cleaner Beed
her breasts during her
protests I also recall the mathematics
professor and director of the National
University Colombia mooning a huge
audience of angry students in 1993 and
although five rode away with popularity
to become mayor of
B the mooning story unmasked
the mooning story
unmasked the baged head by which I mean
that the head and face were no longer
understood to be baged while instead the
anus was unmasked I.E
unclothed as I wrote and rewrote
permutations of this sentence getting
more and more
confused I concluded I was a victim of
some worldly gig of oppositions that
would not let up going faster and faster
truly translation and its bedfellow
rumor are a mighty coupling in place of
the bag head mooning presents the
uncovered anus or at least the promise
and premise thereof via the
bad B this is an especially dramatic
form of
unmasking not only of the bag
head but of the head
face
complex as such highly energizing a
veritable MRA Falls there in the Heart
of
Texas but as I've have tried to show my
early writings on defacement unlike the
Trope of Enlightenment
unmasking seems to not only perpetuate
The Mask his AG but fortifies the
Mysteries therein bound as they are to
Revelation and concealment faith and
skepticism it is usus a superior form of
enlightenment
this is the more fundamental operation
not unmasking as tearing a under the
veil concealing truths but it's leading
to more profound let us say energetic
forms of masking as is achieved by the
blinding image of a bare bottom thrust
in the face of the academic audience
there in the lar
State at least this is the situation is
reported in what used to be called
primitive societies of hunters and
gatherers when the mask is taken off the
owner
man impersonating a spirit in TI del
Fuego the initiates belief in spirits
seems to be
strengthened similarly as regards the
exposure of the secrets of the n fluts
in Harland New Guinea or we showing the
novice that it is the bull roarer in
Northwest Australia and not the voice of
the mother the great mother and so forth
father from dispelling the sense of
mystery Enlightenment in the form of
unmasking seems to strengthen it w
stand's appraisal based on his field
workor begun in Northwest Australia in
the daily River area in the 1930s is
especially telling taking issue with the
usual reductionist approach he writes
that some anthropologists call these
fertility rights but I prefer to call
them Cults of mystery and he notes his
informants talk of their religion as a
joyous thing with maggots at the
center the story of the bag head is just
such a joyous thing with maggots at its
Center this story evolved into the
dizzying depths of a bare bottom
projected outward towards the audience
like a face calling to mind Victor
Turner's description of monsters in the
Lial period of male initiation rights in
the 1950s in central
Africa here in the Lone Star State we
have a face that is an anus and this
anus has spread across the land even to
dick in the midwest there is no backhead
anymore there is no head either just a
naked
butt we have
fallen we have fallen as a bti
fall to what he paints as the absurdity
humor and grossness of the big toe
encompassing the irresolvable dialectic
of the head and the foot
mind and matter Hegel and
Marx start
again we have fallen into the
moall of sheer transgression where the
oppositions are non- recuperable and
non-redeemable there is no dialectical
alaben synthesis or closure just as
there is none with mooning Texas other
than that of a good story which point
blank refuses
resolution at the end of the day what
more do you want thank
[Applause]
you no moving
today you never know what will
happen with that
Let's uh I'm sure there any questions I
have some questions too but let's I want
to open it up to the audience first and
so uh uh this is your chance to ask the
first
question somebody like to
stop here we go we back
here I ask you to introduce yourself to
hi um my name is m and I teach an
anthropology I was very inspired by your
a book on Shamanism and I written a book
on Shamanism as well so but my question
is about um the theorist that you
discussed in the beginning of your story
that refuses to be concluded and get to
the
bottom so um both um this the issues
about issues brought brought by m and
kind um
about the um society's cohesiveness and
Essence and things like that seem to
fall apart um throughout
your uh uh talk and uh how would you
address that more directly and how I
address if you the the fact that um they
disappear or they fall apart um or
both I would say more falling apart um
um so and E presentation being amazingly
um multi layer and also metaphoric uh
doesn't necessarily
critique um the aspect of that very
selected SE selected sort of emphasis on
cohesiveness and and things like that
and I think that this this is one of the
problems that we have in social sciences
that this ever since du time we seem to
look for that and talk about society as
Society but then at the end of your talk
Society no longer exists so would would
you help to put it in such a way that is
more um addressing that
issue
um this the first time I've given
this last week and I was inspired by a
guy called KH in Sydney who wants to put
out a book on energy in art which
there's a sort of apparently a
Resurgence of
interest uh it was strong apparently in
the early 20th century uh d uh himself
was a fascinated uh X-rays were a big
deal Madam K and and so on and so forth
The Fifth Dimension this stuff was in
the air in the 1900 1920 and so for so
now some people getting back into that
thought it was appropriate for MIT you
know now
uh uh I've been thinking a lot about
Mana as a as
a c you sound like you know it tends to
be uh dismissed and ignored um but for
all sorts of reasons one of which was
the way it was translated or reformed by
Li in his uh introduction to Marcel M
and which he moved something that he
thought was uh uh into linguistic into
setic
uh frame of of thought and um
I uh for one reason or another you know
wasn't very happy with that and uh I U
do think that
I'm certainly open to uh suggestions
that much more could be done or more be
more precise about the place that Mana
plays in this uh in this talk uh but I I
do think it it runs as a thread through
the whole piece now I don't uh I don't
um know if I agree uh completely with
you about the dur disappears or the
societ or the notion of society
disappears I don't think that that's uh
um conceivable I mean just it's a
problem with words okay we can talk
about the words but I don't make a big
deal out of it I mean if you don't like
the notion of society as conent with a
nation state or or trial formation then
there's all these sort of
interconnections and so I'm fine with
that but there's something about generic
notion of society which is I think very
helpful uh and I think that the society
is more than the sum of its parts and so
forth is very important Mrs Sater Ronald
re and the have done and that's an
interesting thing to take out so um I uh
I'll think about the uh sort of breaking
apart of the of the categories uh next
time I read it I I did tend to get I
thought the confusion in the last U uh
in my mind when I was trying to rework
the face and the Moon
uh is actually testimony to this big
problem of dialectic which comes unstuck
it it just it just can't resolve them it
starts to get crazier and crazier you
start off with you know a nice set of
oppositions and as you start to SP them
together they undo themselves and that
was of course the famous point of this
or the point of this famous essay by the
time 193 31 or something like that to
break up the hean uh idea of synthesis
and even the Marxist idea of materialism
into
irresolvable uh oppositions and the
bottom line of that was to well this is
a great generator of energy this is the
day P
pass and I thought it was interesting to
think that works as up as energy traps
based on width
W and I like very much uh Joseph for his
honey pump and his lemon and his use of
the different materials for that reason
so um I'll give it another thought I'll
try and work through the man of stuff I
I read a beautiful manuscript if some
manuscript you probably wouldn't like me
talking about it too much or all Willi
Mella Chicago he shared me a four
chapter book on on Mana which I thought
was just just wonderful and he worked on
the power of images in advertising and
India and he's U very taken with this uh
scene and uh he he felt the urge to go
back and examine the the uh meaning of
Mana uh he uses it in a colloquial way
in conversation you know the way we talk
about Charisma or something that he
feels quite strongly that yes seem
submit an
energy it's magical you call it man you
can call it mana and it's fine and then
in the manuscript he he know he crosses
all the tears and dots all the eyes and
expounds on it so I hope he gets that
mant probably fairly
s thank you what else do we
have um it's
probably hi I'm J
um uh maybe this is a less critical
question but what do you think about
this building hold
cler um what do you think
the work uh what do you think about this
building which is supposed to be
building yeah the building itself this
one this one we probably looked yeah
it's a Frank Gary building what what
what do you think about the building I
you well it's supposedly full of energy
and it's forms express its energy and
the weight well I felt I felt very good
in this
building
class I mean University architecture so
so awful or it might start off good but
what the administration does to them
finally is incredible the university
right teachers so unbelievably
bad in this regard yeah so um tell me
more yeah I think the question is about
architecture and energy uh so you've
talked about art and energy um are way
that we can think about and he's
architecture student turns out
so but yeah right might you have some
thoughts about energy and
architecture I mean I have lots of
thoughts that they not
was
just yeah how bad I find where I
work specifically particularly in the
question of uh
heating it's like an institution you
know we always complain about
institutions are so stupid and this and
that but boy how you stupid about
central
heating uh I was in a room where we
almost you know had to take a shirt off
came came stripped down to a singlet and
then I got a screwdriver and so open the
windows cuz they had it all screwed in
and that lasted about two weeks before
they found out sure it was on
Lose
uce
Yourself so I'm palom I am assistant
Global Studies um you so if I understood
correctly there's a sense there's a a
space in which uh there's a
self-generating energy that is not the
same as Cal
BR energy which there's a space Sacred
Space negative Cy space that is that you
describing some of this uh ideas that
there's a self-generating energy space
or or or source that is different from
the capitalist c equal C Prime um and
I'm thinking uh about debt labor cap uh
Marx also calls Capital debt labor and
the matter for how that how that
metaphor Works um to think about other
forms of everyday labor that may might
not be uh that might be different today
uh from from um labor conceived on their
uh production I'm thinking to to clarify
I'm thinking about the Latin American
context a lot of people have been
talking about the informal economy in
Latin America and how that both uh is uh
is uh works with the neoliberal
uh uh regime of production but also
against it at the same time right so I'm
thinking about what kinds of uh spaces
of Labor specifically U might we look at
uh for these other forms of uh uh
generation energy that are different
from uh Cal in CRI well I'm glad you
asked the question because that helps
with the first question a lot um helps
me
um uh
I I think my use of the phrase
self-generating is is probably wrong I'm
interested in um um producing a surface
producing uh extra energy not just
maintaining yourself um maintaining your
and that's why I started to think about
always I thought about in his story of
Texas I always thought about isn't it
fascinating how there are certain
phenomena in society
uh which produce energy out of sort of
nothing or sort of nothing they create
an extra and that's really what this
story is All About and uh capitalism
seems to me to do something parallel not
different parallel C C+ or C C is to be
an example of of creating more out of
less and it does through this strange oh
I guess a slide of hand that's in
involves my reading uh the
transformation of the use value of Labor
into exchange value right and that's
that's that's the moment or you buy the
labor The Exchange value of Labor P it
to use and create more than what you
started with that that sort of idea so
that that's what's very much going on I
mean I'm not that obsessed with the the
max of stuff in this paper and More in
general but it's it's going be quite
wrong to think I see it as suppose it's
capitalism is energy generating machine
even as it's using energy right it's
producing or it's transforming surfaces
I mean now I can see a big discussion
get involved here let me return to the
origin which goes back to the first
question I think the all the simple
point of this talk or simple question I
asked myself is how do we get something
out of nothing or had to get more out of
something less and I kept thinking about
the social
[Music]
Bond and how it's energetic and it
creates
energy creates more energy all the time
and I was thinking this is very
different to limited knowledge I have of
Newan physics which is like you can you
cannot get more energy out of the system
in fact the system is dying
call and I was thinking well Society is
different Society is amazing because
Society is actually this incredible
generator if the Sun is this phenomenon
which is producing all the energy as the
physicist call it and you and I are
calling it now after a few Decades of of
patology and and fear and and and global
warming and we know the sun is providing
every bit of energy here made all this
stuff and so on and so the sun itself is
this Mighty or which will disappear and
I don't know how many billions of
trillions of years okay but what about
soety itself Society is like in this
sense like a sun I mean it's producing
this fantastic forms of energy that's a
simple as that and I thought really
interesting is the way gossip works and
with in the half said and the way things
are invented and elaborated not by a
great
artist filmmaker whatever just by person
a talks to person B talks to person C
and by some don't know what else to call
it mag
of
elaboration through
speech
telephone whatever something
[Music]
bigger what was interesting in this case
I is to go into the specifics because
they are fascinating specifics you know
relationship goes the face to the rest
of the
body yeah but it's a simple as said just
the energy of social
connections and how C social connections
of these are like generators and this I
came up with thought with some
interesting phrases like I was thinking
about uh Jan when he's about to steal
with his friend ye in the porn shell and
I refer to them as little electric
generators of solar panels or little
hydroelectric dams you get the feeling
of his riding I could have gone on and
on you know that in these
encounters something new is put into the
picture high energy new stuff is put
into the picture and it's you can call
it sex you can call it crime they have
to go together uh and then you have to
put it in the realm of the homosexuality
and what he's liting in what 40s 50s and
so on and so but it's this uh crack line
that is so interesting to me I'm not a I
used to be but I found his his uh I
found his formulation quite helpful in
thinking about these sort of things and
he talks about he's so hard to read but
when he talks about wasting and deons
and all these things seem to be pretty
much the same and you could I never
thought about it before you could quite
de wasting living in the fast
land um spending all your money you know
on Saturday night gambling away all your
money and one wild gesture that that was
the sort of behavi that he Warfare
he
same same very negative example of the
same thing yeah so it's as simple as
that and I do see capitalism as a
um I put it in the same
realm so if we talk about Labor we could
talk about something very specific I
guess take a particular job cutting can
for example or embroidery but
uh
that's been
done and we also have this great
metaphors now we always say oh that
person is bad energy you know that
meeting provided such great energy and
you think of it banal cliches
right I'm sort of saying they're not
that
Bal probably have time for just two more
questions while Caroline and gr okay so
Caroline Jones our historian living at
of course the center of the energy
initiative here at MIT um I I want to
return to Voice who also said qu is Cap
art is capital right that was one of his
slogans and I want to ask you would it
make a difference if the light bulb
isn't actually glowing if it is actually
L if it is not actually glowing if there
are no what's behind the question um no
in other
words do we produce the energy for
voices cap if we what do we the viewers
the receivers produce the amount of
produce the energy of Voice's cfree
battery I mean it's not as an art
historian as people know it's not
actually gone right I mean in other
words it
reveals because you know it's not
actually plugged into the grid
so this this is to your point about the
mask coming off reinforcing yes yes so I
want to give you that and
um I was thinking about K's project you
put the I'm particularly like this first
SL because I painted
it this is in the book too right isn't
this this is in your uh I swear I saw
this no it's
not okay yeah it was wonderful to begin
to think that and I was thinking about
K's project through your talk I'm
writing about interview for K project so
we on
the on the same but I just wanted you to
think about the social quality of this
kind of hom homo favor right I mean that
that we make something so someone else
can look at it when we're not there
yeah no that's the
answer yeah hey thank
you more
about thank
[Music]
you oh hi Graham Jones from anthropology
um one of the things I I really liked
about the talk was the way you combine
your work as an ethnographer and then
this anecdotal component of your life as
H academicus and so I was wondering if
you could speak in those two guyses more
to the themes of uh gossip and rumor and
in particular the ways that those kind
of uh under the radar discursive
registers can be simultaneously sources
of insight and confusion order and
disorder inside and what confusion order
and disorder structure and antistructure
yeah hgy and counter
hity too much
confusion
uh I'm glad you ask the question because
I think it's a nice note to end on and
not an easy one uh which is
uh I haven't got got it right it's the
U I don't want to end up with something
pathetic like it's good to have a
story it is good to have a story it's
very important uh I know what I wanted
to say you don't just have a good
story when that beats you
up I mean it's more than just a good
story it's like it's a it's something
that's very important and you think it'
be important to other people
uh it's having a story that talks to
storytelling that would be my
um criteria and that's where the the
so-called Theory might come
in so you tell a story about Siri you
tell a story about
adoro um his notion of what a bour
audience listening to classical music
and what it means when they all clap at
the end that's just it's sort of not a
very profound point you know all clap
and that shows you the primitivism that
they've been restraining and nii has
some
great who was also a great
uh adored music uh you know he he has a
lot of very interesting remarks about
the type of bodily discipline that are
required to listen to uh what we call
classical music but
um
uh yeah it's sort of seran a slightly
different all the throat clearing with
durkheim and uh m mous and hub and so
forth at the beginning um is is a way of
slowly edging into that and also because
I think most people quite rightly would
feel manner is a ridiculous
concept or very
foreign or
hokey you
know uh so it's like there's a bit of
uh laying of the land there that has to
has to be done
but
uh I usually find people who talk about
writing and about stories um are really
boring so we'll stop at that
point can you tell us where this may be
published or or what your plan is plan
no plan this is one of those
incent lemon light balls thank you for
sharing your
lemon
yeah